رؤى جديده لما يحدث للانسان اثناء الموت
هذا ما كشفته دراسه حديثه عندما رصد معدها
حدوث نشاط دماغي شبيه بالوعي اثناء عمليه
الاحتضار لدى مريضين من اصل اربعه جميعهم
كانوا في غيبوبه وغير مستجيبين ومن لحظه
نزع اجهزه دعم الحياه عنهم الى وفاتهم
بسكته قلبيه حلل علماء بجامعه بيانات نشاط
الدماغ ليجد ان اثنين منهم اظهر زياده
بمعدل ضربات القلب بجانب زياده نشاط موجات
جاما المرتبطه بالوعي هذا الامر قد يعني
ان المريضين كان مستيقظين داخليا العلماء
قالوا ان الاكتشاف يتناقض مع ما هو معتقد
في علم الاعصاب وهو ان الدماغ من المفترض
انه لا يعمل اثناء عمليه الموت لكنه
سيساعدهم في الابحاث المتعلقه بالوعي
السري المحتمل اثناء حدوث السكته القلبيه